the reason I'm a good businessman is
because I play outside the framework
you got your perspective
[Music]
what can answer for you my man okay I
mean I'm gonna try to get to everybody
but I mean everyone's gonna kind of hear
about business issues but art and
furniture has been sold through
galleries yes most the time well I'm
starting to change that trend but but
not just art in the sense that it's like
you know thousand dollar are no we're
talking about things that are escalating
into the hundreds of thousands okay and
so now I'm trying to create okay so I've
been successful in doing now we built a
business from zero to now just a little
over two million this year which is
awesome it's amazing but through
traditional PR I'm finding to it I've
been in Architectural Digest Fast
Company although all the magazines but
that's starting to reach its limit right
so how do I increase sales for the for
the studio to keep growing with without
PR yeah so we so once I got out to Gary
I started you know we started to really
go heavy on social started creating more
content now actually have a full-time
video team that's in-house that's doing
so we're creating a show and also doing
a podcast basically doing everything
that you've been saying to do the tricky
part is to get these consumers these
people that are buying high-end you know
spending 60 70 80 hundred thousand
dollars to to buy directly from us and
to grow that because a lot of people are
using interior designers or architects
sure I'm reaching out to them they know
us really well but how do I go even
further like how do I take it to
millions at 10 million you know and so
that's where and I feel like it's a
personal branding I mean it's my name I
want to process it so I just have to
build that part and then see the sales
I've been producing content every day
for 13 years right like only in the last
18 months has it gotten to the critical
enough scale where like it feels like
it's something different than what
you're up to right now meaning like I
had a base you've known me for a while
like I had a base but it's nowhere close
to what it is now I mean when you're
building a brand guys Nike almost went
out of business
like really close so like I don't think
you know I think the you know gonna it's
super simple man like like yelling
started like the answer is what you're
doing like content acting like a media
company and running ads and creating
content and like it's all the same [ __ ]
like when TV is a good deal and not like
Proctor and Gamble like you buy Tide and
like Crest toothpaste because television
was a good deal and the companies that
figured it out and could afford it and
then it like like slits beer and
Schaeffer beer in Ballantine's a
lynda.30
like your great-great-grandfather drank
that [ __ ] because radio was a good deal
in 1937 like the good deal right now in
my opinion is the 7 platforms that live
on this when you take it to the step 2
of actually becoming the media company
not just an advertiser right and that's
where like a CPG ice cream can do both
whereas I camp and cannabis can't and
you know we're all stretched thin you
know like you know think about your
family business with the catering like
when I was 28 years like all these kids
are like it hasn't happened yet I'm like
I was packing boxes of wine and shipping
it and styrofoam in the basement of a
liquor store in Springfield New Jersey
when I was 29 years old like so you're
gonna I'm gonna you're gonna struggle to
get tears out of me that you're four
months into your t-shirt brand and
you're not supreme yet I think you just
have to put in the work for a
significant amount of time because
you're absolutely right my my entire
thesis is that Architectural Digest the
Fast Company in 1996 those two articles
would have changed your whole career
great and and good news because Nick
know is this like weird I mean I'm
spending all my time trying to figure
out how to help like create a business
to service SMB you know we don't know
how to take money here from Vayner
unless you're paying us like two million
bucks you know like we have things but
we're not good at taking it which is bad
for a business so I'm like spending a
lot of time on it but the reason we
haven't done it yet and the reason I'm
hesitant and why
this took five years to like in my head
before I did it is I'm not gonna take
somebody's money unless we can deliver
and at a small base it's just better to
do a lot of things internally like I
think the more I realize I'm like oh
that's gonna end up being consultant or
this really works like you pay ten
thousand bucks and watching all the
people that email Nick and then he tells
me or I see in the in the Facebook group
like there's been some crazy [ __ ] what's
your what's what's been a you know keep
them closer to it okay yeah so like I
think I think the biggest thing I can
tell you is that um is that you have to
make as much content as possible and you
have to spend as much like this is where
people get create this is a very
interesting subtle insight people take
pride in organic reach because they
think there's something special about
getting good organic reach and social
when the ads are under priced so like I
literally would like like if you didn't
have an instant I know you do because I
know some of our limited interactions
but like if you didn't have an Instagram
account right and something as great as
like taco and food and Jersey Shore like
I'd be like you don't even need to build
one just run ads on Instagram you
probably you know it's funny let me
rephrase
I do think having a nice little base for
like I now think people's Instagram
account is PR I feel like people search
Google to find your Instagram account to
get a fee read on what you're about so I
think organic contents value now is
almost more like brand and PR like it's
a cost like you should spend money on it
just to have like a foundation but moat
but that should be 20% of your energy
and money and 80 percent should be
figuring out the ads that drive your
business Sotheby's and Christie's sell
million-dollar items on Instagram so so
selling sixty and eighty thousand dollar
items on instagrams a cakewalk it's
about running ads against people that
live in Malibu yeah
a customer at a 60 to $100,000 price
point it's tough to do yes but but but
but but not as tough as people think
meaning I think so
you know I'll explain give me one second
because I want to give this off because
I don't forget it I think what we're
about to roll out with volume method is
really gonna be a big factor here's what
I mean by that I think it's easier to
close a $60,000 person if you make 497
pieces of content and run micro media
because we're the reason it's hard to
close somebody for 60 K is people go
abroad because they wanted like lower
their CPM or like reach as many people
the reality is to hit somebody 60 K you
almost have to like do a one-minute rant
like specifically like 215 type people
in theory that are likely to buy it and
overpay for five thousand people to see
it that don't have any interest to get
to the 15 and and then it's Upper East
Side african-american male who works in
tech then it's Upper East Side third
generation trust fund baby and you're
making a reference to Ibiza the place
where I've seen that you know it's funny
Nick that one's brought me a lot of like
non results because so many people are
following things from an aspirational
standpoint but buying first party data
of purchase and tender takes that nature
or creating look-alike audiences on
whatever data you already have it's been
interesting I I often say that but I'm
starting to peel back a little bit
because if you're a fan of Phyllida
right like you think you're hiding but
so many people are aspirational and
they're following high-net-worth brands
but they're not in consideration set so
you're wasting media dollars because
you're not really getting to something
this is where like this were like really
knowing your craft though like I know a
lot about wine so somebody may say oh do
Opus one but I know I can do like
romanée-conti Latasha like you know
enough about like
Kampf artists or uh you know there's
like if you can get nerdy about what you
do
that's always a just a very important
insight but I think it's content to I
think one of the but but but it's
interesting about content I think a lot
of people that try to replicate my model
aren't able to get away from the
business goal so like if you're doing
content you need to act as if you're
Architectural Digest not Pablo Picasso
and people struggle with that like it's
the intent behind the content are you
actually trying to replace the b2b
magazine or to be to BC magazine or
program or are you subtly still doing
some version of a commercial wrapped up
in content and I think that's for
example you know we're about to start a
wine project so my lovely partner in
crime is here I would want us to act
more like Wine Spectator than QVC it's
white wine Lambie TV worked you know
when I was a store owner but I really
took and I thought I was gonna do QVC
like I tell people a lot like the origin
stories like I'm about to do QVC and as
soon as the camera want went on I'm like
oh [ __ ] I need to like lifestyles of the
rich and famous or something like I just
knew that I couldn't do cubic like it
wasn't gonna work like if I was just
selling like I just I knew that there
would you know I knew my team would pick
four wines a show I knew inevitably I
would like some of them but was really
interesting it got so clean by episode
fifty all the way to a thousand I never
had a wine on the show that we had more
than five cases of I completely went
content because I didn't want it was a
lose-lose situation if I 200 cases of it
first of all I was so committed show I
could pan it and then it would be very
difficult to sell or I would say it's
awesome some kid on the wine team quits
and just tells everybody how he's just
peddling wine we had 200 cases of that
Zinfandel I didn't want to create the
exposure so when you as you get into
content wherever you are on it I think
the people the part that people struggle
with is the intent when I make content I
am literally in Wikipedia nom
at mode you guys know like I'm very
comfortable making a piece of content of
like by my sneaker like I'm very
comfortable to sell when I want to sell
but I'm not disguising selling when I'm
putting out content
I saw his stickers you know super
important you reviewing another artists
gallery in a video and giving them love
cuz you genuinely like their work is
probably the most significant thing you
can do for your business that's a brain
[ __ ] but then what you're doing is
you're becoming the artists whisper to a
community not selling your [ __ ] so you
need to build trust you know I also
would like to create less friction in
the purchase because well well yeah and
like what are gonna replace that with
augmented reality like there's inherent
friction in one-off I should think you
lean into your friction so I would go
the other way I inherently if I was
making one yeah like I would have Breck
like if it's a hundred thousand you
should have like a coffee with everybody
that should be good like but it should
but all the digital stuff should be
leading to the coffee sir I'm going
instead of like making it feel you know
where everybody goes with this [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] do it on let [ __ ] that [ __ ]
nobody wants nobody was first of all
nobody's mind a $10 item are they are
they a platform so they're taking
consignment cuz they have the attention
same reason eBay like they spent the
money whatever they don't know the
platform whatever they did to build
their brand or customer acquisition or
whatever they become they became a
marketplace and everybody goes there so
they're doing really well because first
of all they're doing really well because
marketplaces when they hit they hit it
really I don't believe that I really
don't I think that nobody's gonna want
to come there if they're if there is an
added value to go there versus what they
think they can do online right so like I
think people want to do more [ __ ] than
ever
because they want to show people they're
doing [ __ ] people go to wineries and
hike and yoga retreat and [ __ ] why do
you think all these weird museums are
popping up people just want to take the
photo in the blue [ __ ] balls or in
the sprinkles or like we are in full PR
mode of ourselves and we are now living
our lives for the Instagram photo people
are literally planning their Saturdays
predicated on the picture that they can
put on so I actually think if you made
your gallery like if I had a gallery I
would just make one humongous thing that
everybody wanted to just come and take a
picture of that's it like put people in
jail for like 24 hours like they come
into your gallery they get locked up
that's that would work like like you
know like just that's how you sure I'm
going people will use online because its
lack of friction for something that they
don't value doing physically but if you
can give them something of value
physically they'll do that we'll keep
bouncing go ahead real quick I apologize
I I think your website should literally
be a complete and utter gateway drug to
have a meal with you you'll sell a lot
of hundred thousand dollar things just a
better use of your time our sounds and
free stuff drum kits and stuff like all
the I can literally it's a sound that
sounds like this and then they put it
together with like some of this like
that yep yep you know so essentially we
sold all the different sound kits and
stuff and we took advantage of Facebook
groups cuz everybody in Facebook groups
just spamming check out my soundcloud
it's like the weirdest like yeah I know
it is so but for us we're like hey how
about you come get some free resources
so we grew really really fast collected
emails
even knew what marketing was in our
space but what happened was is that we
got to like I like that two million year
point and we're profiting you know 75 K
month now at this point cuz we really
fix our profits too now I'm trying to
figure out what are some levers and I
have some ideas for voters and lovers to
get to like you know the eight-figure
point or to go Headley's pass this point
cuz we've been here for you know a bit
so what are you selling kit still yeah
sound kids we've got it on courses and
stuff and we're trying to evolve the
product so that the product come from 47
to now the next we're gonna try it for
97 times we've ever tried it seems like
the the spike in price has always been
something that's raised our revenue just
keep raising the prices making the
product better we've had this also as
problem to our evergreen sales we'll say
that a little bit under 100k but then
won't launch
it'll be like quarter-million for days
so and then you know we do it we sell a
certain buy packs so I think you know
the model that you're running is kind of
like that classic internet marketing
model you know that like kind of really
got into Fame in the years of like 2000
2015 I think the thing that you can
layer is more content more brand that's
how you grow your in sales and what you
need to layer it with is brand like you
know so like I've watched so many people
find the business model where they've
got a price they've got launches they've
got that whole model down its funnel its
landing page optimization it's CAC its
LTV it's all that [ __ ] it's amazing it's
fine it's really good it you know gets
people to a certain level but then
they're in this sales business not in
the brand business like a lot of people
that fall in love with that model don't
think about their logo don't think about
their content don't think about
reinvesting in swag don't think about
putting out a pot you know they don't do
brand like this is why I'm always like
watch what I do watch what I do watch
what I do like and and it's because so
much of what I do is predicated on brand
because that is the ultimate leverage so
I think putting out content like
recording sessions like using your you
know your growth in the space and
building relationship I mean you're in
the best place on earth that Lana is the
best place like so just tapping into
younger artists and doing collaborations
and then running ads against their fan
base and there's a lot you could be
doing but a lot of it needs to now be
less about math and more about art
what I was kind of thinking on that
because I haven't even talked about yep
yep going to that space so I was
thinking about letting the team still do
launches once every three months we have
that revenue and then me and my partner
are good at building out the new team
till I go for that is a good I like that
and honestly like my biggest concern is
that you're making seventy five thousand
a month like you need to be pouring that
back in the business
like I'm desperately curious what's
happening with that 75k because if it's
going into your pockets - like like into
your lifestyle that's bad and that's
what every kid does that's why people
don't business they'll build businesses
that's why people have moments right now
Facebook Messenger for us that's right
it is one clear email - that's it's
insanely good yeah something that so I'm
a little worried about Facebook building
this huge list and then like oh we don't
do that well that's life you always
squeeze the [ __ ] out of an orange that's
full and then when it's empty you go
find a pear which is harder to squeeze
and then you hope them grape fruit comes
along right like that's like email used
to be 90 percent open rate to me it's
not anymore
Google AdWords or five cents a click
it's not anymore like I'm on emotion
like it's amazing it's really I'm really
glad you asked the question people do
this all the time like people get so
emotional about it going away they don't
take advantage of it when it's their
crush my space when it's my space and
then make sure you're good on Twitter
and Facebook when that's happening like
in Surrey do you know how many people
are gonna be vanished when Instagram
starts to slide everybody's paka mitad
the whole [ __ ] world right now is paw
committed I'm like sitting and laughing
I'm like aw man I like wanted to
secretly like disappear because I think
people die
look people be like what and I'd be like
cool we think how we have all these
other things
yes it is but when you have something
like facebook Messenger and kudos to you
for like going in on that squeeze the
[ __ ] out of it but you can also extract
those people's cells and emails and it's
really good you need you need to invest
in your business you didn't invest in
your business
the profit margin you're making we need
to go back into the business on things
that don't bring you short term ROI
that's how you build something from two
to ten that that right I took Wine
Library from three to sixty and I was
paying myself seventy six thousand
dollars a year sixty seven eighty two
you know discipline let me keep let me
keep bouncing do you have a question
well that's very sweet I like it already
can I open it in front of you how was
your trip yeah final week I want to keep
it going what can answer for you I love
that oh this is good I will absolutely
wear this thank you my friend
I will wear this this Sunday thank you
so much yes yes it's awesome in here Oh
in here thank you go ahead
[Applause]
yes so give me one Thank You Vera I'll
direct to consumer yep yep and this year
we're starting off on a solid track to
hit bigger why I so we're trying to
figure out like all of our website
conversions like wait cut half the
conversions come out yeah we did you did
and did you change the meter you were
spending were you getting less qualified
leads you cut it back before the 6.25 or
that's what made you cut it back yep
how many different pieces of content
were you running we were running just to
get everybody in the same page for this
white sneaker for his sneaker we add
certain ads that were costing us $62 to
get somebody buy and some that were 12
the thing that nobody has really talked
enough about and this is really where
I'm going is the sheer amount of content
one like here's what everybody does it
worked
so I'm yelling for five [ __ ] years
because it's so good that you could be a
dope and it works well right like you
didn't know what the [ __ ] you were doing
day wonna and Facebook was returning and
you're like oh [ __ ] Gary's probably
right right like that's what's happening
then it gets more competitive [ __ ]
changes when everybody does then is they
take their twenty pieces of content
against one
they got 400 cohorts of what-have-you
and they're like I'll [ __ ] Facebook's
not as good anymore let's stop instead
of making 800 more pieces of content
Facebook's unbeliev at Facebook can be
better today than three years ago if
you're better at content and copy and
matching it against your targeting got
it that's it that's the answer to your
questions and then there's Instagram
swipe ups and then there's messenger
like all that stuff and we have like not
like 17,000 or whatever messenger one
we'd send out like a messenger put and
we were getting eighty-seven than 90%
opens we're sent them to a free live
training and stuff on there was so many
ways that people got into messenger that
they didn't know that's why they were if
that's what they were upset about I
don't know the details clean it up you
could send one message to get them to
unsubscribe if they don't want it yeah
go up front yeah you're better off
having 4,000 people give a [ __ ] yes says
we're going we're right around 35 to 40
people yes yeah yeah of course
know what I mean we I see some people
you we had honored I guess what's the
best way of creating the culture where
people are like watching
when I came up before you just seeing
how your TV interacts um I think that's
as as small as 35 people you should have
dinner with every single employee and
ask them what makes them happy in life
because you have employees of those 35
you have some people that want to make 2
bucks more an hour you want somebody who
wants more Saturday's off you want
somebody who wants to be a manager now
you want somebody you have somebody who
is happy yesterday but they fell in love
and now they need more time at home more
money title work-life balance
Rick you'll find out a few interview 35
people that there's something weird
going on with Rick and you may have to
fire Rick you know and so when I hear
about how companies that have under 50
employees I can't push them enough to do
you know the one-on-one hand-to-hand
combat that's the answer but but the
one-on-one is where you can start
building the on the third meeting on the
one-on-one Susan will actually tell you
about Rick because in the first one they
won't you have to build a relationship
the smaller the company the more often
you can do it you know mine are like I
text you at 11:30 at night when I'm
flying back from something to be like
yeah and we're like like I'm not kidding
he'll tell you like like whenever I can
get to it kind of like trying so hard
you know
yep yep yep taste which how many
employees are there yep
which you can't imagine how much equity
that builds with the 30 to 40 and you've
been around the whole time just like I
was but it's still gonna be amazing
yep amazing when you flip like literally
literally literally that cut garage yard
like that stuff what's the best I'm
sorry I'm so obsessed what's the best
thing I know what's the best what's the
best thing you found this last six
months how much did you buy for and what
you sell for I love that [ __ ] so much
man I like live on this [ __ ] keep going
okay
yep freaking out yeah yep yep so how how
the business is now structured with you
taking over is everything it it's the
entire conversation because the reality
is you need like do you have the full
autonomy or don't you do you to a point
but blank like these were the things
that really helped it get better and
better and better for me and my dad
at first it was gray as [ __ ] and then as
things would spur up especially when I
had momentum you you don't even
understand how it actually plays out yet
cuz you'll taste it when you start doing
a couple things and it starts working
and then she tries to stop it it's even
worse than not starting at all like once
I started tasting momentum anything that
my dad would try to bring to defense
felt completely inappropriate because
I'm like it's [ __ ] working and look I
don't wanna paint a false picture my dad
gave me
outrageous levels of autonomy in
hindsight and really unfortunately the
only issues we really had were some just
hot-button issues that he was like there
was four things he was religious about
and I was religious the other way I mean
the one I used to keep laughing like he
just did not want to sell product to our
employees that cost that was to him like
he couldn't get over it and I was like
so into it like I wanted to sell at a
loss to our employees you know like it
was a real battle and never actually
probably the reason I probably bring it
up it's the one battle that never really
got settled in our careers so I think I
think a couple things you need to think
about one having empathy for the fact
that your mom spent so many years
building this business which I can even
sense I think you need to map what hurt
her huh so I'd let me take a step back
are this taking over phase is she
looking for you to make all the
decisions
she really was working with the couples
yes yes everything else yeah yep so it
kind of hurt but coming from that it's
hard to spend money and you're seeing
spending money as in like investing in
the business whether in advertising or
something like that does your mom have a
sense of how much she wants or you guys
like to meet what allowed me to over
hire was me my dad had a good sense of
what we both wanted to make in salary
and then basically after that I can make
no money at all so that's why I overt
hired similar to what I'm doing here you
know like I'm not looking for this to be
the money I need to take home thus I'm
pouring it in so I think I think the key
that I'm trying to get into is what's
real and what's ideology and emotion
what I was very good at in hindsight I
didn't even realize I was doing it as a
kid was I was eliminating subjectiveness
and emotion because my dad like lived on
emotional reactions and I got us
overtime to a lot of conversations that
were you know after like crying and
yelling I got us into like you know took
me a while but I just remember these
feelings even right now as I'm sitting
here I'm like okay okay how much money
like do not subject me do not like
opinion of the month flavor of the month
it rained yesterday or we had a snow out
day and now we're and now you're
overreacting to the fact that we did 0
yesterday instead of 80,000 and now
you're not letting me run a New York
Times ad take me to the macro how much
money do you need to make in Sally cool
now get out of my way I will deliver on
that and if I don't then let's have a
combo basically is this sentence that we
got to that really allowed us to explode
it's great and did it go well good
great yeah I believe I talked to my dad
everyday like we were like right we were
in in the store so I talk to him all the
time and that was really what made it
difficult because again like somebody
would steal a bottle of Jack Daniels and
my dad would just emotionally explode
and it would like tear out the next
three days you know like all the energy
and angst was like we have to stop
everything and figure out how not to get
anybody to steal and like okay cool so
we're gonna focus on $28 and let cool
I'll give you I'll do Leah favor we're
probably getting $500 worth of stuff
stolen a month and you want me to stop
everything that's generating four
million dollars that that would
literally be the kind of things like
there's many many people that build
businesses are completely predicated on
emotion ideology every fashion brand
loses because they care too much about
subjective emotion of course B to be
sure the community which it sounds like
you're leaning into and then and then
when something see their ideology or
emotion grounding in in something so
practical and gives you the framework
and then having the the one thing about
idea extra you know there's something
I'm very passionate right now which is
that fake environments that kids are
taking money from parents and building
businesses and nobody's acknowledged
again and it got me down this
interesting path where I realized oh
[ __ ] the kids of this generation are
taking money from parents and don't
think they need to pay them back and the
kids from our generation and definitely
older than us the game was your parents
would help you but you got to pay them
back and something in that is just
sticking with me that I haven't you know
fully got to something but it's kind of
where I'm going right now which is like
you say I said to my dad like look I'm
willing to listen to everything you say
if I'm unable to deliver on what I'm
telling you I can deliver on if you give
me this room like to me like there
should be
consequences if you're not good enough
and I think I'm seeing a lot of people
want certain things from their parents
in a family business but aren't willing
to deal with the ramifications because
there's so much audacity coming from
kids going into businesses it sounds
like you're not that which excites the
[ __ ] out of me which makes me even want
you to lean in but don't get too crazy
so you know like in hindsight don't
realize I was like [ __ ] you know like I
was delusional but I like was so driven
that I made it happen but you know I
think that matters cool dudes I know you
do so like what maybe what's subtlety
underneath that might be like let me
give a good sample you should have an
intern who DMS influencers until the
account gets blocked on 40 different
accounts all day long every day for life
but like but like you heard the last
part you're gonna regret it do it does
that make sense
like if you don't have at least one
person at minimum wage who's just a
scrappy kid who kids [ __ ] without a
board on his head no but I mean this is
super important this is what people
understand this three years ago good
three years ago you got paid how much by
that [ __ ] mattress or subway or what
right but but in him had the ability to
go from zero to build two million dollar
revenue business you're in Boulder
there's unlimited [ __ ] up there who
like can work for 13 hours a day or
whatever is appropriate and legal cuz
[ __ ] Boulder might be 2 hours a day I
don't know how you guys [ __ ] do it
but but like you should have three
people you know any because we all say
we do it yeah tell me the truth on a
very serious note I'm a true question do
you have one person who fully spends 10
hours a day DMing until he's blocked or
she's blocked on 13 accounts great I'm
real how big is your business in revenue
you should have three full-time people
on minimum wage doing it yeah it's it's
the influencer version of you're gonna
be upset that Facebook went away
what if they change the DM rules let me
rephrase what happens when they change
to BM rules you know basically somebody
follows us do the bad thing and send
them coupons and let people give a
positive response because I'll go back
in and engage so it doesn't deceive you
don't goes to other how do those people
check their other people check their
other cool not everybody [ __ ] does
anything it's just math like this is it
the whole game is scaling the unscalable
everybody's looking in this tech world
to find the scalable thing the magics in
the unscalable part we're building part
of like our wine business that if you
buy the club there's a SMS sommelier
service that you get which is like
literally like you go to a nice you know
restaurant in Cleveland and take a
picture and be like what wine should I
drink and we're me included at first me
what do you tell you I'm gonna look at
the [ __ ] picture and be like the late
harvest Zinfandel with your dessert
would be great me I scale the on script
guys every single piece of written word
on Twitter and Instagram is me
if I've ever DMD you if I've ever
replied if I've ever hearted your that's
me
i scale the unscalable I'm as busy as
they get so I'm definitely not crying
tears for anybody else right and so so
now everybody's trying to figure out
like hey how do I incorporate CBD into
my product you know popcorn or lemonade
and so we've got into that position
where everybody's asking us and so we've
kind of reversed it because what we do
is you know resource for Native American
farmers it's very good practice
the genetics are very good so we kind of
built this little nice yeah our
leveraging that niche on other brands so
we have some of the largest CPG
companies in the world and salty snacks
and ready-to-drink beverages saying hey
we want to buy your CBD because it's a
semi trusted you know no name in the
category love it put your logo on the
back of the packaging try to build the
intel of the ham couldn't believe in it
more literally literally pay for those
brands to put my logo on it let alone
get paid couldn't agree more
it's absurd you should spend all your
time energy on it you need hoons
business you need to make as little
money as possible for next 36 months
good give it back
moments in time like you know obviously
like I don't know your life you may have
debt I don't know but [ __ ] is little
by the way everybody that's the advice
that's how you build a business that's
how you build a business you got to feed
your business not buy a new pair of
Supremes
that's just what everybody does and you
know supreme or a house or you know the
great mistake of my career was buying an
apartment I six months before I could
have invested in uber and double down on
Facebook like it made me less liquid
lost a lot of money needed you know I
was grown me I was I just had a child
like like it's not terrible but like I'm
just talking to wonder if I'm gonna
recommend one day somebody people I
actually starting to get weird about
ever owning a house
I think nobody should own I'm starting
to really believe that nobody should own
a home until they're 40 nope I don't
think anybody should spend money if they
have actual business ambition if they
want to build a business for real for
real not I want to create a business to
give me money to then you then you
should extract him what like there's a
people that build businesses to get a
waverunner to buy an RV to like stay at
the ritz-carlton and that's fine that's
you're not building a business you're
trying to create a machine to kick you
cash the problem with that is it always
becomes vulnerable in the end and then
dies and then that's why people go
backwards so funny this kid grabbed me
at the airport were you with me yes
second I'm telling I'm really fascinated
by it his kid runs up to me said carry
me you know like like let's take a
selfie
he's like God I really talked to you
know because I I'm so this is like it
was really sweet he was a nice I just
loved his vibe I was like this is so
meant to be that we met he's like i jus
I just came down here I'm flying back
home I just got super ripped off like
what do you mean he goes I literally had
all my bar mitzvah money and what my
grandma left me and I lost it all
somebody just scammed all of it from me
I'm like how much he's like sixty
thousand bucks so it's really
interesting what happened in that moment
I looked him dead in the face and I said
that's what happens when you try to make
a quick dollar and he goes how do you
know I don't like you can't get scammed
of $60,000 unless you're trying to make
a quick buck you just can't you bought
into some [ __ ] because you thought
60 was gonna be six hundred thousand in
a week and that always always loses
that's the most extreme version but
where I get word and I don't nothing
about you like when I get worried about
kids making some money early on is the
less extreme version is you're taking
money off the table and you're just
living that lifestyle when for 50% of
those kids if they poured it back in
they could really live that lifestyle
forever if they just ate [ __ ] for six
more years and build something for real
you know yes
that's reckoning I think podcast
pre-roll I think podcast pre-rolls
really good I would hit up email every
single podcast like that you think maps
and any [ __ ] you know let's be creative
I'm obsessed with influencers for you
guys and then fully having your own
podcast and your own vlog being a media
company yep that's awesome and look you
could I think there's a way for you to
build a personal brand about being an
entrepreneur and what you've learned and
just letting that halo effect your
business there's plenty of people that
want to I mean what are you guys doing
here right like you can halo it to your
actual business you know you got to be
you got to be very clever like but like
if you make it more about you and not
the business like no reference to even
the business people Google you put out a
good video of like how you ate [ __ ]
before six years and like it does well
people find out who you are they'll go
to Google they'll figure out what
company you work for
so there's ways to run media as you know
as a huge sewer I'm going from there 13
shots just to get on the red went down
Florida open up down there
so cliche Jersey yeah Jersey Florida
[ __ ] makes me so happy but now I'm
looking at like the next 18 years what
do you want to happen I just want to
take the brand to its potential the game
of it I mean yes so then then I think
franchisee at this point you being this
grounded in mature is a good debate it's
a good debate if you want the game of it
and to me when I hear the game event
after somebody who's anybody who's been
in business for 18 years is a successful
entrepreneur you know like like the
amount of people who like make a lot and
then lose it like and that like being us
an entrepreneur saying you're not to
preneur versus being a successful one
it's completely predicated on life cycle
to me one man's point of view the game
of it gets into the vanity of I watched
my dad do it i watch you know with my
fame or I or local Fame or internet fame
it's been interesting to see my dad go
from caring less about money and caring
more about the game actually it was oh
actually that's actually not fair
my dad always cared more about the power
and influence in his industry then like
like being bigger than other stores it
was like like being the king of like big
fish in a small pond it was his passion
you know the ultimate game of it is
becoming [ __ ] McDonald's like you
know here's the good news you're an
operator you don't have [ __ ] 14
stores and not being an operator you
just change your agenda of operation to
making sure that Nick do when he opens
up his shop in Little Egg Harbor
Delaware or the [ __ ] [ __ ] stays on
point your operations change it's like
becoming a manager right you know this
you you it you were the guy for
conserving the tacos in store one
you don't do that as much you managed
over time right well now you're just
managing something else like like you
can have a six-month [ __ ] course till
I get through to you
like you could spend a year picking
franchisees franchisees fail because
they want the money if it's you it's
your baby in the way you've built it I
already know that you that I think
franchisees is the right conversation
for you I'll tell you why I just think
you're gonna be outrageously thoughtful
with your first 10 another how many
employees do you have that worked for
you for longer than five years can I
give you a huge piece of advice any way
that you can put some of them on you
can't imagine what that can do for you
and I don't know what you've spent your
money on how successful you've been even
if you can afford to put one guy or gal
up or you can go to characters like me
like successful Jersey businessmen and
be like yo I'm making [ __ ] up this is
just being creative I'm starting a
sponsorship program for my franchisees
if you actually came and we have had
some light weight interact on social
things that like if you came to me and
said yo weird but you just seem like the
you know I've heard you're this kind of
guy would you go into business
fifty-fifty with an employee of mine who
has no money but it's been with me for
six years and you could own 50% but you
have to put up all the money I got to
tell you I'd probably do one it just
feel it's a version of business charity
we need to have new things like why do I
just have business and then sometimes I
just write big checks some things that
I'm emotional about like like you you
can get me real fast to you give me a
little video on Susan or Hector or
Johnny or Rick and they've been you know
their parents died and [ __ ] they work
for you for seven bucks an hour and I'm
like I'm in I mean when you have 50
people that are like how many people do
you think that work for you right now
you could elevate and actually own their
own version of a store for real for real
any you need to do that brother
what you should do because that [ __ ]
will work and you know it
it's why I love all these little [ __ ]
it's context you can show me somebody
who's better on paper but we know each
other right you can show you somebody
who's run 13 successful Burger Kings
but you know exactly who Susan is and
then you have to worry about the taco
not being good you both win I know it'll
work the best thing that the the reason
I'm a good businessman is because I play
outside the framework that's what being
a bad student is so comping to being
good entrepreneurs it was easy for me to
come up I've never thought of that
concept it was so easy for me after I
even listened to six seconds because I
got enough context to id8 on an idea
that is specific that's why this stuff
has been so fun for me cuz I could put
out content that's you know evergreen
all day long but in the nuances like
it's so like you know like I'm so like
want you to dig into the thing like
that's not scalable you know cuz you're
not gonna be able to change the inherent
nature of a one-off product there's no
scalability in a one-off
what's scalable is you can meet seven
people a day for a coffee and if your
content web does that you're probably
you know you're gonna close to it you
get them to dinner well guess what if
you take them to dinner you'll close
even more
food is always gonna be okay you know q
sr and fast-casual whatever the trend of
the moment is make a good [ __ ] taco
for the right price you'll be alright
especially you know yeah I think that's
right and by the way I say may like a
lot of people have said that about
things that did stick right and other
things didn't right to that point but if
you just look at the basic Latino you
know influence on America your your
grandkids are gonna be fine on that
specific food tacos are gonna be just
fine
and I say II may become the new taco
thing or may not but you're exactly
right course product placement yes yes
yes but you should probably be upfront
with them because you're one blog post
away of like you [ __ ] used me like
somebody did that with me that came to
four DS and that was not a good
situation for that person you know if
your remember in 10th
yo what's great about what why that's
work yo Dawg I'll give you something and
you just use it
I want that exposure you want the [ __ ]
for free bet I then run ads against fans
and fans are hitting me eat me up and
saying yo did you into like what then
the person feels like you got them so
now going I don't disagree with you but
50% of them will like it so you say it
upfront and you're in a much better
place and you think it's no no I do not
know I do not it worked out for Nike
I got it I got it yeah of course I think
you're fine with that I think you're
fine with that I think your your
siphoning attention and then you become
the thing
you